hello there reject Nation I'm here doing
my
obligatory Keanu Reeves impression that
everyone else is going to do leave a
like that would be very much appreciated
guys we got ourselves an official
trailer for John Wick chapter four love
the frick out of this franchise man I am
so excited to see this I love the teaser
trailer they released for this during
Comic Con now we got a two and a half
minute one here learning exciting things
about this film man so let's just get
into it and see what's going on in this
trailer
[Music]
saying goodbyes
saying hello
I hear Donnie Yen's voice you think your
wife can hear you
no
no don't wipe on
Maybe I'm Wrong
flashback
maybe not goodbye I got at least one
more movie Donnie Yen
the new day is Dawning
new ideas no wounds
New Management we've known each other
Danville Skarsgard something huh
who is this
challenge him to single combat win a
lose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table who your family
does please pray for me
above
oh
it's time to get married
or buried
I'm going to need a gun
wow what
the table will honor its word
dogs we will have your freedom
under the old laws Clancy Brown
failure to meet at Sunrise
will result in execution
Last Words Winston just have fun out
there
oh damn yes
[Music]
yes it's amazing way up the stairs
I want you to find your peace but a good
death
only comes after a good life it feels so
introspective hiroyoki Sonata and Donnie
and fighting man you and I left a good
life behind a long time ago my friend
oh it's gonna be such an epic fight
let's
man that looks awesome
looks so awesome
uh let's talk about it alrighty well I
thought this was an excellent trailer
because the first teaser trailer that we
got at a Comic-Con really leaned into
the action and it was short brief but it
was you know the thing you you kind of
wanted the John Wick films that hardcore
action to me even though I don't think
the first one has the best action it's
still my purse I like I like all of them
but it's my personal favorite out of the
three films that came prior to this one
just because of the mood and the tone
and uh just how like Primal and personal
of a Revenge Thriller felt and this one
kind of it's not a Revenge movie this
this one seems like that that Quest
revengeance always lives on with John
Wick however this had something that
felt a lot more dark a lot more
harrowing and feels very existential in
some ways it was like it's like a
funeral March so they kept alluding to
John Wick might die in this movie now if
they did not announce that there's a
John Wick 5 also coming I might be sold
on it maybe he'll die in part five I
think it'd be a bold move of the
franchise for him to go out dying
regardless what this movie will be
exploring at least from what the
trailers are alluding to those
existential qualities you know when he's
sitting down at the beginning thinking
about his wife wondering about you know
is there an afterlife where she does it
exist can can she hear him the pondering
with Donnie Yen's uh Kane character one
of the fun motifs of the John Wick
franchise is meeting a new character who
you find out has like some type of fun
history with John Wick that there's some
background with them even the way
they're capturing it currently at least
in the marketing would Donnie Yan and
Keanu Reeves that even looks personal I
did hear a while ago that that would
probably be like the heart and soul of
this movie their former friendship that
they had I love that dude we're going to
be getting this dynamic between them
that actually feels personal it feels
meaningful versus just like a fun wink
and a fun nod and some of the more fun
clips that we normally get with a new
character who has a a past witch John
Wick but then as the trailer even
progresses more you know the Lawrence
fishburn's Bowery King is even talking
about how you you got to be the best
dressed for your wedding or for a
funeral you know like whatever the hell
he says there there's so many hints at
the possibility of him dying and I and I
keep wondering too he's like John Wick
probably has a Death Wish of his own and
he probably wonders if he deserves to
live or not I think this will be the
first John Wick sequel to not just pick
up where immediately where the last one
left off there's probably going to be a
time Jump which would make sense at the
end of John Wick chapter three dude was
jacked and jacked up like badly he was
he was really he was really messed up
even for my suspension disbelief I was
like can you can he can he really how
could he still operate so this gotta be
a little bit of a time Jump here but the
plot that they have uh unfolding with oh
this like Hunger Games like story
getting involved in a game this time in
order to to get his freedom I think
we're actually really going to explore
the high table this time around this
seems to have a quality of what it must
be like to be a warrior being an
assassin exploration of that I guess
what I'm trying to get boil it down to
in the most basic form is it feels
character study again about the guy or
at least thematically of a study of them
while bringing us the action scenes
because yeah the the action I'm sure is
going to be top-notch when you have a
stage like this set up of of a Last Man
Standing game there's only going to be
one person left everyone else is going
to die you know the body count is going
to be high it's a fight for survival and
I think that's the main thing that
brings it back to feeling like the first
one for me brings it back to that Primal
feeling I don't know how things will get
resolved with Winston after everything
that went down I'm sure John Wick wants
to kill him maybe there'll be some type
of understanding they end up coming
towards who knows who knows who knows
but come on there's so many fun things
to look forward to Bill Skarsgard is a
phenomenal actor right like he's more
than Pennywise it's done a lot of work
work and and to see him step his toes in
here I'm so excited to see what he does
I wonder if he gets any particular
likely great action scenes which would
be
like so different for the guy I think I
can't recall a movie where I've seen
Bill Skarsgard do a bunch of action
maybe it's out there and I just can't
recall it right now he wasn't Deadpool
too you know of course Scott Atkins
getting to be in here as well you know
you're going to get some brilliant
action scenes there the thing I'm most
excited for is Donnie and hiroyoki
Sonata who is a phenomenal actor by the
way always brings such great pathos to
his roles is it in his contract that he
has to be wielding a sword because he
has another sword fight scene in here
and every movie I see this guy in or
even a show he's always wielding a sword
I mean I'm not complaining I feel like
it's you gotta do it I was even randomly
rewatched the rush hour franchise at my
own time totally forgot that he was the
main bad guy in rush hour 3. and even in
there he has a sword fight scene at the
end I'm like damn for decades this guy's
just been doing sword fights I don't
know the backer on him but you know it's
just kind of uh humorous to me that that
always seems to be the case so yeah and
even this is not going to be the last
one of the friend franchise it feels
like a movie that is also encapsulating
all the movies that came prior looks
like they're tying it all in you know
they bring up the John Wick family you
see them from chapter three in here got
Bowery King bringing up the vibes from
the first movie maybe in the fifth one
is when you get like the Cinematic
Universe Collision of all the John Wick
characters like Halle Berry might return
in that one or or Ruby Rose even you
know like get get all the people who
survived from the previous films to come
back in one more film which would
actually be a cool John Wick five but
with this one it looks dark it looks
meaningful looks personal looks
introspective looks mournful it's my cup
of tea man what did you guys think about
this John Wick 4 trailer leave your
thoughts down below subscribe leave a
like all right guys catch you all soon
foreign